so today county leaders from across the
state coming together now to discuss the
recent surge in cases
and 8 news now reporter kate houston
breaks down the latest from the state's
covid19 task force
during the state's covit 19 task force
meeting health officials not
that there available wide community
spread of covid 19 and there are
potentially many undiagnosed cases
the nevada hospital association says
while this is causing an increase in
demand
it's also causing some staffing
challenges these are
related to staff members and staff
family members
catching covet or being exposed to covid
through the community through community
spread and then
needing to be quarantined or
self-isolated for a period of time
during the meeting each county was able
to give updates on their mitigation plan
or provide recommendations to governor
sisilak
while the state is limiting large
gatherings to 250 people or 50 percent
capacity whichever is less the southern
nevada health district recommends
capping groups at 50.
the health district's recommendations
for nothing greater than 50 is is doing
a good job and i think that's going to
help solidify some of our our things
coming forward
so we do not have any recommendations
for what the governor's office should be
doing
other counties on the call did not
provide formal recommendations for the
governor either
with that said many were in agreement
that while enforcement efforts are
working
they still need to get much of the
community to follow guidelines in place
kate houston 8 news now okay thanks for
that report we should point out that
hospitals even with the staffing
challenges are currently
stable